if you see the water do this
get out fast
if you don't you might get caught in a
Riptide
what are the warning signs
and which direction should you swim if
you want to survive
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were caught in a Riptide
every year Beach lifeguards rescue tens
of thousands of people
four out of five times it's from these
rip currents also called Riptides but
you can avoid them keep track of
suspiciously calm areas between the
waves and watch for different colors in
different spots this could indicate that
a Riptide is churning up sand sediment
and seaweed
but wait what are they
rip currents are strong narrow channels
of fast-moving water flowing directly
away from the shore
if you get caught in one you'll be
pulled out into the lake or ocean
further and further from Shore they
could form any time when waves crash
into the shoreline or a sandbar it could
concentrate the current
as the incoming water rushes back out to
sea it could create a powerful rip
current
your sunny day is about to turn into a
living nightmare scenario that could
kill you one moment you're splashing
about enjoying the water the next you're
knocked off your feet and the water is
dragging you away from the shore
if you lose your balance the current
could pull you down along the bottom
this is rare but if it happens the best
thing you could do is relax your body
that will help you come back to the
surface
typically rip currents move at speeds of
up to 0.6 meters per second but some
have traveled at two and a half meters
per second and unfortunately you're
caught in a quick one
within seconds you're 12 meters away
from the shore and with each second the
current will pull you further away
your first instinct would be to begin
swimming back to shore but that would
waste your time and energy even an
Olympic swimmer would struggle to swim
against a current this fast
if you aren't a strong swimmer and you
keep fighting the current you'll feel
exhausted and risk drowning and it'll be
hard to breathe
the rip current would be pulling you
under the surface
and then I'm sorry to say it but it
would be game over for you
but luckily you're watching this video
so if you do get caught in this
life-threatening situation you'll know
what to do
the best thing would be to relax don't
fight against the powerful current
instead swim away from it on a 90 degree
angle parallel to the Shoreline
but that wouldn't get you any closer to
safety would it
well surprisingly it would eventually
you'd swim to a place where the current
weakens and stops pulling you outward
generally Riptides are only about 25
meters in width so if you don't struggle
directly against the water's flow you
likely won't have to swim too much to
escape the current
now you're free from the powerful moving
water so you should be able to swim back
to Shore or you could try to regain your
strength by floating on your back
if you can do it this would also be a
good time to call or wait for help from
a lifeguard
once back on Shore you'd feel pretty
happy that you've cheated death but the
danger wouldn't be over just yet
within 48 Hours you could have a
condition called pulmonary edema yeah
while you were struggling in the rip
current you could have inhaled some
water it could have reached your lungs
and irritated their inner linings
then fluids May begin building up which
could make it difficult to breathe
you might start coughing feel sluggish
and have chest pain your body would be
depriving itself of oxygen if you
weren't able to get to a hospital soon
your lack of oxygen could lead to
permanent brain damage or Worse death
but now that you know the best method to
escape a Riptide you'll be less likely
to struggle against the rip current
you might even spot the riptide before
you go in the water
you know the best tip could be to avoid
the most dangerous beaches
they include Mexico's Playa zippolite
known as the beach of the Dead
and at Hawaii's hanakapii Beach over 83
people have drowned in the powerful rip
currents
also don't go doing something crazy like
trying to surf in a tsunami
and that's a story for another
what if
[Music]